hello welcome back we just want to bring  you um some breaking news we  are hearing reports of a shooting in  denmark  now the danish police are saying  that several people  have been hit in the incident at a  shopping mall  copenhagen police are saying that  several people have been hit so that's  many injuries that potentially  could be in place there this happened  where we heard the news just after 6  30 um in the evening so so quite a busy  time  for people milling around shopping um  they're at the scene dealing with this  uh breaking news at the moment that a  shooting has taken place and several  people have been hit at this shopping  mall  the location of the shopping mall is  just half a kilometer from a harry  styles concert that was due to happen  later this evening  but several  casualties will be reported after  copenhagen police saying  that several people have been hit  in that incident in denmark